a so-called Fire Dragon Dance meant to
sell the magic of Hong Kong especially
after dark widespread political protests
followed by the pandemic have taken
their toll on the economy that this
campaign hopes to reverse and with
China's reopening at the start of this
year Mainland visitors are back in force
this is my first time to visit Hong Kong
we are old and we want to see the world
Hong Kong gives me the impression that
China is great and strong China finally
Rises up the territory's luxury goods
stores are busy once more but most
visitors are on discount group tours
that do not spend big
business is even worse than before the
Border reopened although there are more
tourists businesses not improved
[Music]
hello from Hong Kong whatever the crisis
political public health or economic Hong
Kong has a reputation for bouncing back
helped by Brash campaigning but with 80
percent of the new arrivals being from
mainland China Hong Kong is still not
attracting the international visitors it
once did and local people themselves
have changed the way they spend early
closing pandemic regulations it seems
have had a lasting impact people's habit
change are their consumption pattern
change
um I think some people find it reluctant
to go out to spend money in the evening
time the city is also competing with
other Asian destinations for tourism
dollars while more Hong Kong people are
visiting the mainland where their money
goes further the domestic economy on the
mainland is not so good they're going to
other places like Japan where it's very
cheap and locals here are going away for
the weekends to Shenzhen and spending
their money there where it's much
cheaper hotels are about a quarter of
the price it costs um here so this
important period is going to be very
telling as to how many tourists we get a
lot is resting on this golden week to
help the territory's flagging fortunes
Rob McBride Al Jazeera Hong Kong
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera